a nun no-good lame your 17-year old girl
I was called and I'm gonna become a nun
and there's really nothing that you can
say that's gonna make me change my mind
good afternoon all of you since
unfortunately God can't be here to run
this convent himself my voice will serve
as a stand-in for his you'll be spending
the next six months as postulants after
that would enter the novitiate
any questions put your hand down sister
postulants don't have questions and you
are free to go home what is this you're
reading something to do with this
Vatican 2 our Pope has suddenly turned
himself into some sort of reformer well
that's a good thing perhaps changes do
you think the church is in need of
change I happen to think the church is
perfect the way it is are you still
couraging all of your wishes for extreme
acts of penance I would like you to use
the discipline on yourself that's gotta
stop I don't think you really understand
what this difference
we're not supposed to think about each
other because we're not here for each
other we are here only for God maybe I
could just touch your head of course and
you can really not sister touch like
that foods going on here she looks like
she's Indians I think it's wrong with
you to keep us in the dark a church
Union at work my community even my
identity and now the church is trying to
invalidate all of that same none of it
matters so my question is what is it
that really does still matter
[Music]
you